nous sommes en plein dans le scénario
catastrophe le liban a rétrogradé en
deux ans du statut de pays
moyennement développés une statue d'un
pays d'une voie dans une situation
déplorable
[Musique]
non
voilà un billet d'un dollar
et puis donc de 1997 à 2000 19 le dollar
valait ça enfin la vallée de saas est un
billet de 1000 livres donc ça va les
1500 livres voilà et maintenant à
l'instant nous parlons le dollar vaut
tout ça c'est à dire dix neuf mille
livres donc en deux ans le la livre a
perdu environ
95% de sa valeur et ce n'est pas fini
[Musique]
c'est la banque centrale libanaise est
en train d'imprimer de très grandes
quantités de livres pour les mettre sur
le marché pourquoi pour pour financer
l'état pour payer le déficit de l'état
donc comme l'état libanais fonctionne en
livres libanaises donc payer ses
salaires en livres libanaises et cetera
donc on imprime des quantités massives
comment en face il n'y a pas de dollars
la quantité de dollars est extrêmement
réduite par rapport à l'offre de livres
eh bien il ya un effondrement très
rapide de la libanaise au delà de ça il
ya une très grande crise il ya une crise
de la balance des paiements il ya une
dette non remboursable à telle enseigne
que le liban a déclaré forfait sur sa
dette en devises en mars 2009
[Musique]
le quotidien des libanais il est
extrêmement difficile voire
insupportable aujourd'hui la plupart des
libanais vivent avec en moyenne huit à
dix heures de coupures de courant par
jour au mieux quand ils ont des
générateurs privés qu'ils arrivent à
payer les libanais vivent de plus en
plus sans médicaments sans oublier le
fait que les salaires des fonctionnaires
publics ont été divisés par 20 donc le
salaire moyen d'un fonctionnaire de
l'état était peut-être de 1000 dollars
environ il y a encore deux ans et bien
mille dollars ces 800 euros eh bien
aujourd'hui c'est 60 70 dollars 50 euros
par mois donc puisqu'on peut faire avec
un salaire pareil
[Musique]
faut mettre en place des politiques qui
sont exigés par la communauté
internationale le liban est un pays trop
petit et n'a pas assez de ressources
pour pouvoir se refermer sur lui-même le
liban est un pays qui vit sans
électricité aujourd'hui et sur base de
générateurs privés qu'ils n'arrivent
même plus à fonctionner eux mêmes parce
qu'il ya plus de ma zone parce que nous
n'avons plus les moyens de payer tout ça
donc il ya une déperdition d'énergie et
de moyens énormes et bien si le livre
met en place les conditions d'une
administration productives et des
infrastructures performantes ça
repartira plus vite et de manière plus
saine cette api qui mérite c'est une
population qui peut avoir un niveau de
vie élevé mais voilà il faut cesser de
vivre dans le chaos
[Musique]